tender sweet and best of all festive
this birthday cake is our go-to and we
have a few tricks to make it perfect
maybe you've made this from the box
before but today if you want to up your
game you have come to the right place
and after many tests and tons of
sprinkles oh my gosh so many sprinkles
we've come up with the ultimate birthday
cake
[Music]
for this recipe we want to bring all our
ingredients up to room temperature to
ensure we get a uniform batter skipping
this part can cause your batter to break
you could also end up with gummy spots
and holes in your cake yikes if you're
pressed for time you can speed up this
process with a couple of tricks cover
the eggs with lukewarm water make sure
the water is not hot we do not want to
cook them for milk you can microwave it
for 30 seconds and for the butter you
can fill a heat proof glass with hot
water pour it out and place the glass
over the butter
we do not recommend you to microwave
your butter while our ingredients come
to room temperature we can prep our
baking pans the most accurate way to do
this is to place an eight inch cake pan
on a parchment paper tray circles then
cut it out
you can also do the folding method
featured in our chocolate cake video
check out the link in the description
it's really whatever you prefer then
spray your pan with cooking spray add
the parchment circles and spray again
this is going to ensure your cake comes
out in one perfect piece our pants are
ready so let's make the batter we tested
so many versions of this recipe and
figured out three secrets to get our
amazing birthday cake our first trick is
choose the right fat we landed on a
combination of whole milk
butter and sour cream this dynamite
combo gives us a perfectly balanced
tender rich and moist cake we'll add our
sour cream eggs and egg whites into a
bowl mix these then add vanilla extract
and the milk a lot of white cake recipes
only use egg whites but we're using
whole eggs to add an extra layer of
richness
our second trick was choosing the right
flower we tested both all-purpose flour
and cake flour all-purpose flour
definitely works but we like cake flour
best because left's lighter and finer
texture which gives us a more tender
crumb and our last trick is the reverse
creamy method
we will add sugar to a bowl then sift in
our flour with the remaining dry
ingredients
this is important because it breaks up
lumps of flour and adds air always sift
your flour and your leaveners together
place this on a stand mixer with a
paddle attachment and give them a quick
mix
slowly add cubes of butter with the
mixer running on low typically recipes
will have you clean your butter and
sugar together before adding other
ingredients but we like this method
because it helps us prevent gluten from
forming which ensures we get the tender
crown we want we'll do this until it
resembles a dry coarse sand like this
now we'll add in our wet ingredients
slowly it's gonna take a bit of time but
don't rush it
and finally it's time for sprinkles
there are so many sizes shapes and
colors to choose from
but when making a birthday cake you
gotta go with rainbow sprinkles gently
fold in your sprinkles we like to do
this by hand so we don't over mix our
batter it's so beautiful it's like a
party in your batter
pour the batter and you prepare baking
pans and bake at 350 degrees for about
25 to 30 minutes or until an inserted
toothpick comes out clean next we're
gonna set the cakes on a wire rack and
let them cool completely it usually
takes about an hour it has to be
completely cooled before frosting or
you'll have a melty mess on your hands
while our cakes are cooling let's make
our frosting we tested cream cheese but
felt it was overpowering we also tested
swiss meringue buttercream but found it
to be too heavy our favorite by far was
the american buttercream
it's light so it's easy to spread and it
doesn't overpower the flavor of the cake
with buttercream frosting it's really
important to have your butter at room
temperature whip your butter until it
turns creamy then slowly add your
powdered sugar so it doesn't go
everywhere it might get messy here
i like to add about a cup of powdered
sugar at a time once that's fully
incorporated add in your cream vanilla
extract salt and continue whipping this
is called whipped butter cream heavy
cream makes the frosting lighter and
fluffier than the traditional
buttercream salt enhances the flavor
our buttercream looks so delicious now
we can assemble our cake we slice off
the domed tops to make our cakes ready
for stacking it's best to use the
serrated knife here
now for the icing on the cake we'll add
the icing on the cake first add a thin
layer of frosting onto the cake board to
stabilize the first layer of the cake
you can skip the cake board we just like
it for an easier transportation
now we'll add the first layer of cake
and two scoops of frosting on top we
like to use an ice cream scoop for an
even layer of frosting
and when in doubt add more frosting than
you think it doesn't have to be perfect
we're also using a cake wheel
these are great because they spin and
make your life so much easier when
decorating a cake we want to get a
really smooth surface on the top so we
like to place the third layer upside
down once the top layer is placed we
apply a crumb coat which is basically a
thin layer of icing that goes on top and
around the side of the cake to seal in
any crumbs
this just primes the cake for an easier
and cleaner decoration
let your cake chill in the fridge for 15
minutes and then we'll move on to my
favorite part decorating when it comes
to frosting and cake we like to start at
the top and work our way down to the
sides an offset spatula is your best
friend here this is how you're going to
set yourself up for success
if decorating is not your strong suit
you can give your cake a revenge edge
use the tip of an offset spatula to run
it up the side of the cake while
spinning the cake wheel do the same
thing on the top
yeah this works this this looks nice
but we're not doing that we really want
a smooth edge a tip for this is dipping
your spatula in hot water then drying it
with a towel and running it around your
cake this helps melt the buttercream a
little bit which helps create a smooth
finish
if you're fancy and have a bench scraper
even better use it to finish smoothing
the edges just like this getting a
perfectly smooth cake takes time and
patience just keep practicing
and if you're extra like us just pipe
more frosting on the top because you can
never have enough you can really
customize it however you want this is
your work of art
we like to keep the festivities going so
we're adding some more sprinkles on the
outside on the sides and on the top
now it's time to party and eat
if you want a perfect slice we recommend
heating your knife or dipping it in hot
water before slicing your cake
we like to think this recipe takes the
cake
my birthday is july 5th in case anybody
wants to make me a cake you can find
this recipe and many more on tasty.go
oh yes
[Music]
you